mais il a cogéré avec la FNSEA et les
agriculteurs sont sortis dans la rue
avec leur tracteurs pour réclamer des
revenus à la fin ils ont moins de
normees environnemental mais toujours
pas de revenu en fait donc là il y a eu
aussi des mesures concern non mais il il
y a vraiment rien de structurel qui
permet de changer la donne sur le plan
du revenu et il y a surtout rien qui
permet d'anticiper les effets que va que
va avoir le réchauffement climatique sur
l'activité agricole et en fait je pense
qu'il y a une inquiétude légitime et
importante dans le monde agricole de ses
Chang
qui enfin les agriculteurs ont
l'habitude de dire qu'ils gardent un an
de récolte enfin un an d'argent d'avance
pour essayer de gérer les mauvaise
récolte là on voit que les années de
sécheresse par exemple se cumulent les
unes aux autres et qu'en fait les
rendements agricoles dans certaines
régions de France commencent à diminuer
sérieusement donc il y a quelque chose
de structurel à aller chercher on n'est
pas du tout là-dedans et je rappelle
quand même que la FNSEA a une espèce de
main mise sur le monde agricole dont il
faudrait questionner la pertinence et la
légitimité parce que le mode de scrutin
dans les chambres agriculture leur donne
une espèce de pouvoir bien bien exagéré
par rapport à ce qu'il à ce qu'il
représente léitime la fnso pour vous B
en tous les cas ils ont un mode de de
ils ont un mode de désignation dans les
chambres d'agriculture qui font que qui
fait que ils mettent ils ont la main
mise sur le monde agricole et là on le
voit ils ont négocié essentiellement
pour les plus gros je pense que Arnaud
Rousseau le directeur de la FNSE est
très satisfait des des mesures qui sont
prises je ne suis pas certaine que les
petits agriculteurs qui peineent qui
sont à la peine qui n'ont pas d'emplois
ou très peu d'emplois sur leur ferme et
qui sont avec des des des horaires de 70
ou 80 heur par semaine soit très
satisfait de ce qui sort mais sur les
revenus il y a quand même une pression
qui est mise sur les distributeurs pour
revoir la loi égalim il y a 1550 milli
qui ont été annoncés de soutien fiscal
pour vous c'est c'est rien non non sur
la loi alors sur la loi égalim je
rappelle quand même que la grande
distribution à ces centrales d'achat a
mis ses centrales d'achat à l'extérieur
de la France Leclerc est à Bruxelles
Carrefour est à Madrid et SuperU est en
Hollande pour bénéficier du droit
hollandais du droit espagnol et du droit
belge que d'ù la volonté d'un égalisme
Européen et le discours de Gabriel Attal
et d'Emmanuel Macron qui disent il faut
respecter la loi française même quand on
négocie France fa s'en prendre à ces à
ces grandes distributions à cette grande
distribution y compris par une taxe sur
les surprofits qu'ils ont fait pendant
l'inflation puisque je rappelle que
leurs profits ont explosé pendant
l'inflation donc ils sont des profiteurs
de crise et puis derrière il faut des
prix planchés et il faut revoir le
système agricole pour que chaque
agriculteur soit respecté dans son
travail dans sa dignité d'agriculteur là
on n'est pas du tout là-dedans
c'est-à-dire que par exemple je prends
un exemple ils ont annoncé des contrôles
par la DGCCRF 10000 contrôle par la DGCC
répression des fraudes par la répression
des fr par les grandes surfaces euh sur
dans les grandes surfaces les les
inspecteurs de la DGCCRF donc de la
répression des fraudes ont
été diminué il y a un/4 de de ces
inspecteurs qui ont disparu en en un peu
plus de 10 ans donc en fait tout cela
n'est que de encore une fois un
ministère de la parole et mais je pense
que là ça commence à se voir qu'il n'y a
aucune espèce de capacité ni à négocier
ni à monter un rapport de force et qu'à
la fin on tape sur ce qu'il y a de plus
facile c'est-à-dire les normes
environnementales mais je rappelle que
les normes environnementales ne sont pas
là pour embêter qui que ce soit ils sont
là pour protéger notre
santé la planète vous nous dites que
l'écologie est perdante dans cette
négociation elle n'est pas perdante elle
est piétinée elle est piétinée est-ce
que aujourd'hui à l'heure où le
réchauffement climatique s'emballe et où
il devient hors de contrôle est-ce qu'il
est vraiment pertinent d'aller piétiner
les normes environnementales enfin
vraiment est-ce la priorité du monde
agricole les chercheurs parlent de
maladaptation quand on fait ça
c'est-à-dire que on ne trouve pas les
bonnes réformes dans un problème qui est
structurel et systémique donc non là
l'écologie est piétinée est-ce que c'est
vraiment responsable de la part d'un
chef de l'État et d'un Premier ministre
que d'accrédit le fait que le problème
c'est l'écologie honnêtement je pense
qu'on est pas du tout rendez-v de c'est
pas ce qu'ils disent personne enfin en
tout cas Gabriel n' jamais
ditèmeécie si parle d'écologie punitive
en permanence et l'écologie n'est ramené
qu'à quelque chose de punitif je
rappelle quand même que dans le plan
écofyo il y avait cette volonté de
diminuer les
pesticidesise cause que mais bien sûr
que si c'est en pause bien sûr que
si il y a des clusters de cancer d'fant
dont on soupçonne que les causes soient
lié aux pesticides je rappelle qu'and
charante maritime il y a des parents qui
se battent par exemple pour que leur le
cancer de leurs enfants soit reconnu
comme étant lié au pesticides c'est ça
qu'on est en train de de casser avec le
plan avec la POS du un problème en
France et pas seulement qu'en France
c'est qu'on demande aux agriculteurs de
faire autrement mais ils n'ont pas
franchement d'alternative quant au
produit à
utiliser non mais c'est la question
c'est pas une alternative quant au
produits à utiliser sans ch changer le
le mode la manière de faire agricole
c'est ça le sujet c'est que si vous
continuez à vouloir faire du maïs de
manière intensive pour aller les vendre
à des centrales d'achat qui vont les
revendre sur des marchés financiers pour
une spéculation mondiale et être en
concurrence avec le maïs du monde entier
si vous voulez faire ça alors évidemment
vous avez besoin de produits
phytosanitaires mais précisément la
question c'est comment assure-t-on la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France et
non pas une agriculture exportatrice qui
est en concurrence avec les pires
pratiques agricoles mondiales et en fait
mais l'année dernière srine Rousseau on
a on a on a moins on a moins produit de
maïs on a produit plus de tournesol
c'est bien la preuve que les
agriculteurs changent mais les
exportations agricoles si vous regardez
les exportations agricoles ça reste
majoritairement des grands céréaliers
qui sont en concurrence encore une fois
avec des pays qui n'ont pas la même
législation écologique est-ce qu'il faut
s'aligner sur le bas la réponse est NON
et puis par ailleurs je je je le pose
ici parce que je n'ai pas beaucoup
entendu mais il va falloir aussi qu'on
s'intéresse à la manière dont nous
consommons puisque aujourd'hui le la
part des produits transformés dans notre
alimentation a progressé c'est-à-dire
qu'on prend des plats toutou fait des
petits fours déjà fait et cetera tout
cela met en danger le monde agricole
puisque à chaque fois que vous utilisez
un produit transformé ce produit
transformé peut avoir 10 50 ou 100
ingrédients dont on ne sait pas d'où ils
viennent et à quel prix ils ont été
achet
[Musique]